Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
And welcome to Home From Work 2
Now this is, uh, a horror game,
and a sequel to Home From Work 1,
which I cannot remember if I've
played it or not, or if I've-
oh..
*black screen* uh-oh
I thought that was game
*click noise* oh boy...
Okay well this is a nice place...
Sure am happy I'm home from work.
Ohhh I wish the mouse sensitivity was just the slightest bit less.
With this thunder I should probably--
have a flashlight ready-
Oh! Left it on the kitchen island
Good... Okayy...
Here we go...
Ooo... Did not expect that to
actually open there... Ohhkay!
Do I have a wife? O-or kids?
Or a friendly ghost that lives here?
Anything of the sort. *click noise again*
I think that's gonna be a big negative on
that one, big papa! I'm just gonna go
and proceed to turn on the lights
all throughout the house, which everyone knows is
the perfect way to stop demons from eating you. As soon as you turn on the light negates all the
demons, instantaneously
Oh no I have an att- I have an att-
I have an attic.
*Click noise* Why?
Why?
Why? Why woul-
HI?
Was that my little scamp of a kid?
I mean I'm in a house with like, four bedrooms, you'd think I'd have someone else living here... Ooh shit that was dark.
I ain't afraid of you.
'kay I'm assuming this is master bedroom... maybe?
Is this my bedroom?
Hello?
Why am I mysteriously checking every room in the house?
...can I go up to the attic?
No. Alrighty then.
OhHKAyy
(Sighs out Alllllright)
OI FUCK YOU
no no no no no no no no
I'm gonna open this door, and you're gonna tell me who you are...
TELL ME WHAT YOU WANT, WHAT YOU REALLY REALLY WANT?
Anything in the attic? *door falls* Ah...
Ohhh!
Unnn seems like my lights are acting up again, what the hell is happening today?
I don't know, but maybe I should go in the attic?
*hoop* *hoop* *hoop*
I'm up here now
I *phft*
sincerely regret my decision to come up here,
but here I am, and here is where I will stay.
Hello?
Hello? Ah, hello! Ah, a key! To the basement, that I keep in the attic...
Just so I can have a scavenger hunt for myself, every once in a while.
Okay then...
Ohhh no you don't...
Oh don't do it...
*thunder* HEY FUCKING YOU- I KNEW IT
I KNEW IT
I'm not afraid of you...!
'kay, so these are all borked and nordled and no longer working
but I got my flashlight and 70% battery left
*realization* I didn't need the basement key then, did I?
Because you're just gonna open up already...
Alright, I see how this is...
Ohh good...
OHhh good...
*breathing* oh, is that a ghost breathing on my neck--
or is that supposed to be me right now,
because one is welcome, and one is cowardice!
Oh boy...
*gasps* what the fuck was that...
Nothing! It was a whole 'lotta nothing
Whoa... Okay, it's a stain... It's nothing...
Bobuski!
I did it!
I fixed my lights...
Just as I had always intended after the thing could stop-
breathing on me, that'd be great.
'Imma go back upstairs now,
because what could possibly happen to me next?
Hopefully nothing horrifying
*banging* fffuu-cking hi...
Who's in my house...?
Or was that in your house?
Honestly, who can tell?
Oh boy...
I'm just gonna take my time up these stairs...
Very slowly...
Hellooo?
Somebody upstairs?
Why did this kitchen go out?
I didn't turn this off...
Uh oh...
*click click* *click*
Oh, okay... There we go... Alright then...
He's just dickin' with me, oh you just dickin' with me
Oh, I see you just dickin' with me, you're turning things off...
Hello...
Hi...
My name is Markiplier,
Ffffucking HI!
*baby cries*
I DON'T HAVE A BABY,
I DON'T EVEN HAVE A WIFE...
I live in this big 4 bedroom by myself...
*strange moaning sound*
*baby cries*
*wiggles finger* Ah, nooooo
Hi?
*click*
Oh, what is that? What is- *moaning gets louder*
Fuckin' hi
Jesus, stop!
Ohhh, noooo
Ohh, noo
*screaming*
Fucking hi!
Okay then... That's not cool...
Fuck youu...
What the fuck!?
He's gonna break my eardrums on me...
Fuck, what was that? And I don't have any commentary on that...
I'm just gonna be like
Ah! The furniture fffloating again.. I see that every Tuesday...
Alright, so I'm gonna go back upstairs,
Oh, not gonna think to get out of this house...
Just gonna go back upstairs and see what's for, up here....
*high-pitched voice* Did you... Did you just fall?
Did you just fall?
Did you just fall? I think you fell...
Alright...
Can I go to bed yet?
Can I just- Can I just go to bed?
Oh... Nice and dark up here...
But I don't think there was ever any light...
*giggling*
*gasp* Fucking hi... Okay, don't do that to me, you sack of shit...
Don't do that to me... Don't fucking do that to me...
*deep breath* I don't like that at all...
Okay...
*breathing*
Ye- *gasp* FUCK hi.. Okay, alright, that's normal
*squealing*
Alright, you just keep squealing off into the darkness, 'Imma go down to the basement,
because
HIII
What is the glowy?
Oh, what is the glowy?
Pray tell- whoa fuck me...
Oh no, oh no... I don't wanna do that....
Mm, ah, I don't wanna do that... *click*
Alright, okay, alright... There's a chair here... (Dainty Chair Charlie!?)
But that says sit on it? No.. Okay...
'Imma go down here...
*breathing* 'kay.. Dunno why chairs are so spooky...
They were my allies... in Amnesia...
*click* *breathing*
Okay, well, that's okay...
Oh, what's with the chewy goopy?
What're you doing?
Okay, I get it, you're crying like a little BITCH, but it's okay,
you got Markiplier here, the bravest YouTuber here there ever is...
Alright, let's go back and see what was behind the...
da red spewky
Okay...
Alright, NOTHING apparently...
Apparently a whole 'lotta nothing, it's just this CHAIR that's out of place...
*breathing*
Alrighty then...
What was that?
What was-- I did not-- I did not click anything...
Ohhhh no...
Oh no...
I don't have enough battery for this...
OH no...
Running 'outta battery...
Rrrriiiiight now.
(Right about now...)
Funk soul, brother...
Anything up here?
*breathing* NO.
I'm dead
I got no battery!
The fuck?
*Breathing...*
What am I supposed to do?
Wut am I supposed to do...
THERE'S NO MORE RED CHAIR GLOWY...
Uh oh...
UH oh...
UH OH 'skettios
UH OH 'skettios...
I dunno what do do...
*inhale*
OOH Whoah!
Hi...!
Hello!
Hi!
*Giggling..?*
Okay...
'right then...
Now I'm completely lost...
I went into the basement, and I have no idea what's going on!
*more breathing*
Okay,
alright, then, I'm gonna skeddadle 'outta here...
so I had to, uh,
I had to get back into the game,
Huh.
Now, I have, uh,
plenty of battery left...
I am COMPLETELY on battery power now...
That chair has stopped glowing red...
I'm gonna go downstairs and see if I can find me some eyes...
Helllooooo!
Hiiii!
*Crying?* Whoahhh... fuckin' hi...
Okay then...
Gonna try this again...
*click click*
NNNOPE, okay, what am I doing, I have no idea, OKAY
I DUNNO...
Okay, guess I'm going back upstairs before I run out of battery...
Ughhh...
Hello?
Hi...
*Screaming*
FUCKING Hi!
BWUH Duyuh...
I don't know what it was, Andy was alright yesterday, but now he isn't, Andy's remarks was always staying late with his friend who always seems to be having problems with himself. Not long ago did his friend duh-DIE by something possessing his home, or maybe possessing him, ever since Andy came back home from visiting his friend he told me he heard noises at night which he could not explain, it started with minor thumping, then progressed to loud banging, and lastly, now, his death. This leads me to believe whoever enters the home of the devil, will soon be killed in your own home. Could I possibly be next?
Um, yeah, I think that's a CERTAINTY,
Is that the end?
I ran out of battery, like, 2 seconds before the end was actually supposed to be there!
Ah, man, I'm a dick.
Alright, but anyway, so I think, I think that's it! There's nothing more to be done! So anyways, that is Home From Work 2.
I can't remember if-- Whoah...
Thank you for playing Home From Work 2.
So that is Home From Work 2, so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching, lemme know what you thought down in the comments below.
Tension mode just says, the monster is there from the beginning
The devil itself is chasing after you.
So maybe if you want an extra challenge with this game, along with the spooks, you can play that for yourself.
So, thanks again, everybody so much for watching, lemme know what you thought of this in the comments below,
and as always, I will see you, in the next video. Buh bye! :D
*Outro music plays*